voilà je ne sais pas si monsieur
persenda pense la même chose
mais enfin il va nous le dire au balo un
panneau un bon moi je suis je suis de
mère anglaise de père italien je suis né
à l'étranger mais je suis français je
paie mes impôts ici j'aurais pu signer à
monaco dont j'aurais pu vivre là bas
mais j'ai préféré vivre ici l'on suit
comme notre premier ministre
la france m'a tout donné je me battrai
pour elle et donc j'ai créé une société
une start-up quelques décades de sa
quatre personnes aujourd'hui nous
faisons pas loin de 400 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires nous sommes numéro
1 en europe dans le domaine des
emballages ménagers c'est-à-dire et de
la biotechnologie puisque nous
fabriquons des sacs biodégradables aussi
avec civile en france qui représente 10%
de la production qui va vers l'europe et
des usines en italie en espagne aux
pays-bas en grande-bretagne en allemagne
et je dois vous dire une chose était
hier soir avec eux mon directeur des
relations humaines qui m'a dit est ce
que vous vous rendez compte que les
relations humaines en france sont plus
nombreux sont tout le reste en nombre de
personnels dans tout le reste de
l'europe
nous sommes huit il faudrait peut-être
maintenant songer embauché un avocat
parce que nous sommes travail est un
cabinet d'avocats à plein temps est ce
que vraiment nous pouvons plus donc il
m'a dit et puis c'est devenue ubuesque
vraiment ubuesque alors moi je voudrais
vous parler d'un certain nombre de
choses la première c'est que
premièrement on peut produire en france
et être leader européen
on est le dernier des mohicans tous nos
confrères sont partis en pologne en
thaïlande en grande bretagne en chine
nous sommes les seuls à rester ici et
nous sommes quand même leader européen
mais ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
alors que l'italie était presque aussi
compliqué que nous l'italie est en train
de devenir un pays qui ce qui facilite
facilite le sens code du travail pour
les entreprises
je ne parle pas des autres même
l'espagne est nettement meilleur que
nous alors nous je voudrais vous parler
d'un certain nombre de points
premièrement je voudrais vous parler des
syndicats nous avons eu 12 heures de
grève en 30 ans et nous avons quatre
syndicats et moins de 4 % du personnel
et syndiqué donc ça pose un problème
sérieux ça qui n'est pas compris par les
délégués du personnel en disant pourquoi
est ce que eux sont élus sans être élu
alors que nous nous représentons quand
même toute la force vive la société des
sociétés deuxièmement je voudrais vous
parler de l'inspection du travail qui
sait le politburo ça tous mes directeurs
généraux ont été à la gendarmerie
certains étaient en correctionnelle ils
sont pas sortis de la mort mais enfin
alors j'ai même été chez le préfet qui a
dit l'inspecteur du travail
départemental de dire inspecteurs du
travail local arrêter quand même dit je
ne peux rien dire
il est totalement indépendant je ne peux
rien faire jeudi mais arrêtez vous
toutes les usines en bas à genoux si
vous continuez comme ça et ça c'est un
grave problème d'avoir cette
indépendance totale inspecteur du
travail qui fait ce qu'il veut comme il
veut quand il veut
troisièmement je voudrais vous parler la
médecine du travail aussi la médecine du
travail
nous avons à peu près en moyenne 7 à 9 %
d'absentéisme régulier mais ça je dire
dire que si les gens sont malades sont
je le comprends tout à fait mais nous
avons à reclasser des gens dans lequel
le médecin du travail n'est apte à aucun
travail et nous devons demander à toutes
nos filiales
si on peut trouver un job pour quelqu'un
qui est apte qu'un travail alors nous
rentrons l'ubuesque le plus total et
même oui exactement
donc ça c'est alors je dirai ensuite je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec
à mon voisin que si on ne foutez la paix
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait bien travaillé
et je veux dire que c'est dur c'est de
bure moi je me suis battu pour maintenir
j'avais un directeur général qui m'a dit
faut fermer nos deux usines françaises
ça ne fait que trois cents personnes
licenciées on va en pologne
je me suis battu je les ai maintenu en
france et je suis je veux dire que
c'était envers et contre tout et je dois
dire que de ce côté là je suis très fier
d'avoir gardé parce que vous pouvez pas
savoir à quel point à quel point les
gens qui travaillent dans ces sociétés
familiales
il ya là notre société qui est une
quarantaine d'années maintenant sont
fiers du travail que nous avons fait
ensemble
mais il est exact que si on faisait
simplement un calcul purement et
simplement de faciliter le travail
nombre d'heures de 44 heures en pologne
payer le quart etc etc
on pourrait penser que on a un gain
fabuleux en pologne
et bien mes confrères qui ont installé
en pologne n'arrive pas à voir
l'automaticité le rapport homme travail
que nous avons en france on a quelque
chose d'extraordinaire mais alors de là
à être dans une carton avec ce
magnifique machin là ça c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment impossible pour
nous et vous rendez compte que cette
personne pour 700 personnes ne
travaillent que pour ça c'est quand même
dimanche alors que je n'ai même pas une
en italie
j'avais une demie en espagne et la
facilité que nous avons eues en espagne
en espagne à ce que le losc la crise est
arrivée
il y avait une augmentation générale de
5% des salaires
nous avons convoqué le personnage choisi
l'espagne en disant écoutez on ne peut
pas ils ont dit ok 00 mais le jour où ça
redémarre
vous êtes à leurs essais 5 % sur cinq
ans et bah nous avons réussi sa et
société espagnole et plus prospère
aujourd'hui malheureusement que me
soucier de normandie où le haute-loire
et grâce à ça
grâce à cet accord que nous avons pu
avoir et sans difficulté avec un vote à
70% 30 étaient opposés mais ils ont dit
ça mais alors ne pouvons pas faire ça en
france
et ça c'est vraiment dramatique donc
nous avons quand même un challenge à
faire en france parce que je suis
persuadé qu ici
vous savez en angleterre pour empêcher
quelqu'un en dix ans luca le cas alors
qu'en france
l'attachement qu'on peut avoir du
personnel à sa société est quelque chose
absolument extraordinaire mais il faut
sortir de l'ubuesque dans lequel on est
actuel merci on entend ce que vous dites
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de talent et
de force on l'entend évidemment beaucoup
chercher vos collègues votre voisin mais
mes chevaux collecte d'une manière
générale madame charbonnier tout à
l'heure la dit d'autres l'ont dit avec
évidemment à chaque fois des points plus
précis où différents selon ce que vous
vivez dans vos affaires
c'est quelque chose qui est répandu me
semble-t-il chez les chefs d'entreprise
qui sont les premiers concernés par le
droit du travail comment vous expliquez
vous qu'il y ait eu une telle dérive
entre le droit du travail et les besoins
de l'entreprise
alors hier hier mon drh me disais
écouter à l'assemblée nationale il y a
que des professions libérales
il n'y a que des gens d'administration
il n'y a pas de chef d'entreprise donc
les pédales que le problème est est-ce
qu'on connaît vraiment à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat ce qu'est
l'entreprise
et voilà le problème j'ai donné des jets
des bêtes j'ai donné des bétons pour
nous faire battre je m'excuse auprès de
mes collègues qui sont ici qui disent
chacun oui oui on connaît on connaît
l'entreprise je pense d'ailleurs que
l'assemblée comme le sénat ont tassé le
l'assemblée nationale vous avez énervé
monsieur taugourdeau oui je pense quand
même que et claude greff
je pense que l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat ont un peu évolué et que et qu'il
ya plus de chefs d'entreprise ou en tout
cas de personnes issues du monde privée
qu'auparavant je rejouais notamment un
sénateur jouait le sénateur d'assaut par
exemple quelqu'un qui est kate kate
issue qui est patron d'une petite tpe en
province
je crois qu'un intervenant à
l'intervenante politique tout à l'heure
a fait son mea culpa en disant que
droite comme gauche on s'est un peu
trompé un pendant des années des années